spider-man and venom two great tastes
that taste great together
yummy
the multiverse cracked wide open in
spider-man no way home paving the way
for all sorts of characters bad and good
to make the leap across franchises and
enter the marvel cinematic universe in a
crossover foreshadowed by the
post-credits scene if sony's venom let
there be carnage the lethal protector
himself shows up in the first
post-credits scene of no way home which
picks up shortly after the venom
sequel's shocking tease after seeming to
cross universes and let there be carnage
and seeing a news report about tom
holland spider-man no way home
definitively confirms that venom and
eddie brock were pulled into the mcu the
no way home footage shows eddie and
venom seated at a bar as the symbiote's
human host comes to terms with
everything mcu-related that includes
thanos the infinity stones iron man and
the blip thanks to a patient bartender
who's there to explain it all but when
eddie suggests that he and venom go and
see spider-man in new york to talk about
their situation he and venom are
suddenly pulled back to their universe
those events leave fans with a pretty
big question after the dramatic events
of spider-man no way home will venom
ever come face to face with spider-man
some form of venom and spider-man
fighting one another on screen again
seems like a sure thing not only because
they fought in the world of marvel
comics but also because sony pictures
holds the rights to both the spider and
the symbiote the only potential
roadblock here is marvel studios had
kevin feige and the studio's plans for
the mcu the entire relationship between
sony and marvel and disney is really
unprecedented in hollywood history and
it's all because everybody loves
spider-man thankfully sony and marvel
seem to have formed a solid working
relationship so it's highly likely tom
holland and tom hardy will share the
screen in a marvel adventure at some
point that said it's not hard to throw
two marvel characters together and shout
fight a compelling plot will go a long
way to making the meaning of these two
figures feel natural after all a lot of
leg work had to be done to get them in
the same universe let alone the same
arena the most important thing seems to
be carving out a story for their matchup
that makes sense please scooby-doo this
crap when asked about the prospect of a
crossover in the wake of venom let there
be carnage holland told total film
magazine i genuinely don't know it was
really exciting to be a part of that
film obviously tom hardy is one of the
greatest actors in the world i'm happy
to say that he's a lovely bloke but i
haven't really given it very much
thought meanwhile back in august hardy
told esquire i would be remiss if i
wasn't trying to steer any kind of
connectivity obviously that's a large
canyon to leave to be bridged by one
person alone and it would take a much
higher level of diplomacy and
intelligence sitting down and talking to
take on an arena such as that the only
question left to ask is how the two
characters might meet up in the future
and the answer possibly lies in the no
way home post credits scene when eddie
is yanked out of the mcu he leaves
behind a small piece of the symbiote on
the bar it feels like a safe bet that
that bit of black goo will find its way
one way or another to peter parker
depending on what happens to that dollop
of symbiotes venom could theoretically
have a face-off with spider-man in the
mcu now whether tom hardy is involved or
not and now that the multiverse has been
blown open for both characters eddie
brock could well make a return visit in
the future or vice versa venom tells
eddie and let there be carnage that the
symbiote collective mind knows all about
the multiverse already if a fight is in
the cards for them venom at least would
be ready this all leaves us with just
one question who wins in a fight between
tom holland spider-man and tom hardy's
venom that's a topic for another day on
my planet i am kind of a loser like you
but here we could be more excuse me
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one